can someone give me a more descriptive
definition of what rational means okay
great
can be expressed as a fraction and the
way that we know that that's what it's
talking about is because ratio ratio
when you say we were just looking at um
you know dividing an interval in a ratio
it's like this to this dividing it into
fractional components right so rational
functions now we've met rational
functions before right this is your
classic rational function and it gives
us a hyperbola right something with a
hole in it so this is free standard
though there's no stairs and you get you
could shift this thing you can shift it
left or right or up or down you can
stretch it reflect it all that but um
these kinds of things are going to be a
little more complicated
okay so I've got for you kind of a
five-step process now I hate thinking
about steps is just okay if you just
mindlessly go through this then you'll
be able to work out what this shape
looks like however the same time being
fluent at a skill at an algorithm lens
your power and allows you to analyze
something so to help you remember what
my five steps are okay I want you to I'm
gonna write some words on the board and
as I write them I just want you to
pronounce them okay this very good this
is why I'm so glad I'm a native English
speaker because um this makes no sense
makes no sense whatsoever my it's barren
where and it should be it should be we
even ordered that it should be that it
could when we write this we say
spherical right like early strange
two-spirit good so so this this is mine
this is my crazy English crazy English
moment now if we wanted that to be
pronounced the right way then you'd kind
of spell it like this like that that's
that's fair right like that's
unambiguously spit and that's my own
that's mine the money for how to graph
rational functions now these words they
go in a certain order I did my best I've
actually modified it over the years I
used to have a version that you couldn't
say because it didn't have enough vowels
in it it was just like I'm really like
yeah and you're like what is that okay
um I could I could make a proper word
out of this by putting the S at the end
but as you'll discover very shortly
um the order of these letters actually
is quite important okay so write this
down and these are these are five steps
for how to graph a rational function
okay so I'm going to do something a bit
difficult which is showing you all the
steps first because they're a bit tricky
on their own rather give you one example
and we'll look at there are different
ways in which these are useful okay so
it stands for symmetry you want to take
your rational function and see if there
is any kind of symmetry to it secondly
you will need to factorize the reason
why you factorize is so that you can
note some particular very useful
geometric features that you're gonna
need to put onto your graph namely have
some trans and intersex
okay this last step is not always
required but for the harder ones it is
an enormous ly useful tool but it's kind
of that - the trickiest part of the
whole thing and R stands for regions so
it's a it's not always necessary often
by having by the time you've gone
through the four-step okay I've got
enough information here I can I can work
out unambiguous with where this goes but
uh this number one is very useful and
number two it's quite powerful once you
realize the insights that it gives you
about the function okay so these are our
basic headers now let me tell you about
the particular things that we are
looking for in each one because some of
those um symmetry on Friday you learnt
about the kinds of symmetry that a graph
can have what are the two kinds awed or
even we've alluded to these before right
so we're looking for odd or even okay
that's that particular you're looking
for in surgery
now just let me make note here why is
this off front most functions the vast
majority of functions start there are
neither odd nor even they're just not
symmetrical okay however we give you
very specific functions which often find
a test if you understand whether this is
and also if you do nail whether it's an
odd or Avene function and you you get
that right at the right the front end
it's quite easy to determine whether a
function is odd or even or not and if
you get it right everything that you are
about to do is halved all the work
you're about to do is half because if
for instance you work out it's an even
function okay once you once you get for
example an asymptote somewhere like say
x equals two if it's an even function
it means it's symmetrical this way so
right away you have another asymptote
namely x equals negative two right and
then when you work out intercepts and
then when you work out these so if you
spot some symmetry straight away right
you have half your work so that's why
it's worth doing factorize factorize it
one fraction often what she'll be given
is for example if we if I gave you this
right I could add something to this
morning okay
so I could I could add that right now
this is a rational function but it's
it's not written as a rational function
of the way it's written is the sum
between the rational function and a
constant okay so turn this into a
properly rational function I need to put
it all as one fraction which would be 1
plus x1x
okay and then you would factorize if an
8-bit this is already factorize because
it's so simple
okay so if what's given to you is in a
whole bunch of pieces put it into one
and then factorize okay ah next step
asymptotes okay this is gonna be a big
okay there are three kinds or two fool
but three really important kinds of
asymptotes that you can find what are
the kinds of asymptotes that we know
about okay the first the first easiest
type of pattern to find is a vertical
asymptote okay and then after that you
get my baguette a horizontal or what we
call an oblique asymptote we will talk
about those particular kinds of
asymptotes be the funny thing is they're
actually like the only thing these guys
have to do with each other in common is
the fact that they have asymptotic
behavior but the way you get a vertical
asymptote and the way you get a
horizontal or oblique asymptote is
completely different also there's a
fourth kind of azimuth and I'll tell you
about later because you don't need to
worry about it really but they're still
interesting and I'll show you okay
intercepts that's pretty simple there
are two kinds and you're looking for X&Y
so that's just like any other normal
function and then the last step regions
we're looking for where the graph is
either positive above the x-axis or
negative form or the x-axis so we're
looking for positive or negative regions
okay